Well here here's a name that many of us
know here oh okay our next guest is Emmy
award-winning TV host actor and producer
we're talking about Tamara Maury Housley
she Burst Into the Spotlight in the 90s
with her twin sister Tia on the hit show
Sister Sister
[Music]
I was adopted
I was too you were when were you born
November 28 1979
no no
yeah
you're my sister
you're my sister
nice to meet you
now Tamara is out with a new book you
should sit down for this a memoir about
life wine and cooking oh I like those
things it gives the world a glimpse into
her personal life and she joins us first
first right here on CBS Morning and
welcome thank you you guys are so
warming I know we're hoping maybe you
might bring some wine and cookies I know
I did not it is too early right now but
uh I do love them actually together you
can get the book and live vicariously
through you yes I do talk about food a
lot and and wine you talk about your
life your children your journey I talk
about everything you do what do you want
people to take away from this because I
think people feel like they've known you
you know they grew up watching you yeah
you talked in the green room I know
I will say but this is the thing okay
the one thing that I want people to take
away is that you know I didn't live this
perfect life they usually see me and
they're like Tamara you're always so
happy you always look very joyful and
the thing is is I choose I choose to be
happy my circumstances do not like
Define me and then also I wanted you
know my readers to know you know you may
have a rough start but you just have to
move forward and push through but you
also I always say you can't cheat at
life you know it doesn't come come easy
you're not going to grow as a person if
you don't look at your your trials or uh
you know maybe negative experiences and
face them head on the book is about
growth the book is about my wisdom that
I have learned along the way I've always
been an old soul and uh when I was
younger I always felt a little bit
self-conscious about that but now I have
learned that that is my gift right and I
want to share it yeah and it's okay you
know to be this young person and and
have you know um this old kind of Tamara
is like you call them in the book I do
yeah
words of wisdom Nate's got his own you
do they're burlesons
oh I like that we borrowed that from his
old colleagues good morning that's right
that's right but you have one in
particular I wanted to ask you about uh
choose your friends if I'm a render
correct choose your friends
yes
absolutely for me
um you know wine is very subjective
um but now owning a winery and you know
tasting lots of of wine I don't want to
waste my experience and my taste buds on
bad wine and it's the same thing with
with friends you know you you eventually
you either change your environment or
your environment is going to change you
another Tamara ISM that it's not in the
book
um but yeah I feel like you are your
closest five people around you so it's
okay to be picky right with that you
become who you hang out with 100 yes um
you also talk about family babies
um and you talk about balancing work and
also being a mom just having a family
you say it's okay sometimes to just hide
out in the class in the closet in my car
in your car in the bathroom they
eventually find me break down because
mothers sometimes fathers deal with a
guilt of not admitting that they feel
overwhelmed well yeah and
um it's basically me telling myself that
I I need some me time and when I give
myself me time it's not selfish it's
self-care and I am a better mother I am
a better you know wife I do have a
little sign that says uh please do not
disturb now
um but you know what it's not just me
that needs it my husband of course you
know needs it and it's important to take
that time because you know we as parents
you know I I know for me I always
thought my parents were like these
Heroes
um but they're human yeah and we have
our moments and yes there there have
been moments where I felt overwhelmed
and I was like I just need just give me
15 20 minutes of alone time so I can
hear my own thoughts and uh also you
know just just gather myself and and be
strong you know yeah I like that yeah
I know that's the thing and I preach in
the book a lot too and I wanted to make
sure to that I'm not talking at you I'm
we're talking together talking together
because a lot of people can identify
with them yes as a mother who's
struggling with fourth grade math right
now yeah I appreciate this
we have to go but by raising the
eyebrows by raising the eyebrows is
there going to be a sister sister reboot
oh yeah everyone asks that I have not
given up but right now
thank you so much for joining us you
should sit down for this is on sale
today